because if these women were serious you
know what they would have done they all
would have fired their agents
and they would have went to the mail
room of one of these big agencies and
found a woman that was busting her up in
there and said if you want to talk to us
then you have to talk to her
and if they did that and she would be
big and they would be big and nobody
would get fed to Harvey Weinstein but
did they do that
no
was that their idea no surprisingly it
was mine when I think the feminist
movement needs to be very successful as
a male leader
[Applause]
foreign
I'll do it I will I will lead you women
to the promised land
I will make sure you get equal pay it
will work I will make sure that nobody
harasses you or [ __ ] with you on the
job I will protect all of your interests
and all that I ask for in return
man I'll be scared to call 9-1-1 for
anything even if it's like a fire or
anything because they take those phone
calls
I see the shows they tape them and then
they play them on television that's
[ __ ] up
now I'll say anything if I'm scared that
[ __ ] is private you know
what if I get killed
they start playing a 9-1-1 tape on the
news I'm dead I can't explain myself to
my buddies and [ __ ]
be watching the news
we have Regis Chapman on the scene rich
what's going on out there
I always say it's a guy on the scene a
minute
hi Bob
hi yes we just got hold of a copy of
Dave Chappelle's frantic
9-1-1 emergency call
remember viewers some of this language
is disturbing
hello emergency hey
sir where are you oh oh [ __ ] on myself
let's stop crying
they played that [ __ ] 30 40 times a day
one of my buddies will be in my funeral
looking at me
you know they [ __ ] on themselves
it's hot on the news died crying like a
[ __ ]
[Applause]
the dead I can't defend myself
that's not a nice thing to do that's not
a nice thing to do I mean it's 9-1-1
tape how to expect you to sound of
course you're gonna be scared
it's an emergency there's nobody calls
9-1-1 cool and relaxed and that [ __ ] was
sound ridiculous hello emergency
hi
hey 9-1-1 how are you
yeah
uh look there's a group of hooded white
men Gathering outside of my house
and it looks like they mean business
get out here [ __ ]
I gotta go
foreign
she says my daughter is coming home for
the holidays oh that's great news I'm
glad you're not going to be alone then
she goes on and on about how great her
daughter is I guess her daughter got a
new age and she's out in Hollywood she's
in movies and on television and all this
stuff and she's telling me there's
something this woman is so sweet she
probably doesn't even know who I am or
what I do for a living because I know
but your daughter's out in Hollywood
doing and then she goes would you like
to see her picture oh man I don't want
to see This Woman's picture but what am
I gonna do like okay yeah sure I'd love
to I'd love to I'd love to see the
picture and and I grabbed the picture
and this is all I say this is all I say
oh
she's very beautiful and as she puts the
picture away she she looks mean all of a
sudden like she caught me in some kind
of trap what does that face mean and
then she goes
she's transgender
think to myself oh this [ __ ] does know
who I am
I got a lot of things to talk about
tonight first of all I've stopped
smoking weed
with black people you didn't let me
finish [ __ ] God damn I'm sorry
black people to break the news so
publicly but I can't smoke with you
anymore
every time I smoke weed with my black
friends
all you talk about is your trials and
tribulations
sick of that [ __ ] I got my own problems
thinking that's a waste of weed I'm
smoking weed to run away from my
problems not taking on yours
now on I smoke weed exclusively with
white people
calm down [ __ ] you win by
default
[Applause]
you got good weed conversation
all white people talk about when they
get high
is other times that they got hacked
[Applause]
that [ __ ] all night dude remembered
Frank's last week it's [ __ ] smashed
man
and catalogs everything they drink it
two shots of Jager
kill four bong hits men
beer
cheeseburger
that [ __ ] is great only bad part is you
cannot
pass out around white people
half time white dudes
pass out around each other they always
do some borderline gay [ __ ] when the
guys are sleeping
Frank fell asleep so we like stuck a
carrot in his ass and put shaving cream
on his balls like why [ __ ] why'd
you do that to a friend he was he
trusted you enough people around you
gonna put a carrot in his ass that is
that nice
[Applause]
I'll tell you right now if I put a
carrot and a black dude that [ __ ] will
kill you when he wakes up with some [ __ ]
like that that is an automatic death
sentence on the street it's a rap for
you I'm gonna kill that [ __ ]
[Applause]
I thought y'all was friends baby
what happened
I fell asleep in this house right we was
drinking and I fell asleep in this house
and and while I was sleeping right
I'm just gonna kill that [ __ ]
all right that's all you need to know
we [ __ ] parents
but I wasn't saying anything like
Caitlyn Jenner's a bad person I'm not
mad at her for doing it not even mad at
Sports Illustrated if I'm mad at
somebody I'm probably just mad at myself
you understand because deep down I know
that I am not strong enough to not look
at those pictures
and I don't think I'm ready to see what
she's trying to show me
so Caitlyn goddamn if you go through
with this thing [ __ ] you better go hard
or go home
I want you to go all the way hospice
style do you know what hustle style
means miss that means spread the lips
[Applause]
how she surprised her lips and there's a
itty bitty dick inside
the show is behind the curtains
can't do everything
maybe we
gotta do something do a little weeds
folks we weed's not as bad as everything
else
weed is a background substance
I mean you can smoke some herb and still
function
and you ain't crisp
but your function
oh
nothing higher than weed though
I made that mistake one time
I was at a party some guy gave me some
[ __ ] he's like here man take this it's
[ __ ] mushrooms
I took it I forgot all about it you know
then a couple days later I found that
[ __ ] in my pocket I'm thinking why not
because I'm thinking it's like we some
background [ __ ]
I planned my whole day out like it was
weed
I'll chew this [ __ ] up then I go to the
barbershop get my hair cut and then I'll
see a movie foreign
[Laughter]
like an hour later
and it's funny because I was just
thinking to myself I was like oh
this stuff sucks
tastes like athlete's foot
I feel sick but I'm not really high
then I looked in the mirror
I saw the Barber's reflection man
it looked like it looked like a big
penis was cutting my hair
freaked out
I started talking to myself Dave calmed
down
you're on drugs
this is what drugs do
that there was no way
better penis can cut hate
but I started freaking out man I just
couldn't take it anymore I jumped out
the chair half my head was cut I didn't
care
I heard I didn't I just gave a bob a
handful of money
it was weird the balls opened up anyway
I
I ran home man I ran home as fast as I
could
tripping tripping
look at the clock it was 2 42. I was
like damn 242.
I got a sober upper
I never been this high this early
foreign
I was still high said maybe music will
do the trick
I listened to every CD I had
I was still high
exercise that's what I'll do I ran
around the block four times
still high took a nap woke up [ __ ] up
I look at the clock it was 243 I said
God damn
Come a Little Closer
don't make me go too far
don't stop until it's over
[Music]
years ago I made a mistake I didn't even
know I had done anything wrong I had
written a sketch
that had the word [ __ ] in it
so she sits me down we have a nice
conversation she tells me oh the
sketches are great I go oh fantastic
well then why am I here
she said because David there's no way
you can ever say the word
[ __ ] on our Network I didn't know I did
anything wrong I didn't try to defend
myself I said all right [ __ ] it I'll
take it out have a good afternoon and as
I was leaving it occurred to me hey hey
Renee quick question why is it that that
I can say the word [ __ ] with impunity
but I can't say the word [ __ ]
and she said because David you are not
gay I said well Renee
I'm not a [ __ ] either
I was at home with my son busting he
said Dad I need 250 he's only 12 years
old so I freaked out what's going on
[ __ ] somebody trying to kill you
he said no no
Kevin Hart's coming to town and I wanted
to see his show I said well how much are
the tickets he said they're 125 he said
God damn I only ate it
I said why you need 250 then it goes
because I want to go with you Dad please
and there it is
so I took him to the show
Kevin takes the stage Crowd Goes [ __ ]
nuts thousands of people
I was Furious
along with the show went on the matter I
got
because his show was [ __ ] outstanding
it was mapping these people were [ __ ]
holding their stomachs my son was
slapping his knees
well [ __ ] I do this too
foreign
Sesame Street this is much better
because now he'll learn how to count and
spell
but now I'm watching it as an adult and
I realize Sesame Street teaches kids
other things and teaches kids how to
judge people and label people that's
right
they got a character on their name Oscar
and treat this guy like [ __ ] the entire
show
they judge him right in his face Oscar
you are so mean isn't it kids
yeah Oscar
you're a grouch
it's like [ __ ] I live in a [ __ ]
trash can
on the poorest [ __ ] on Sesame
Street
nobody's helping me
then you wonder why your kids grow up
and step over homeless people get it
together Grouch
[Applause]
get a job Grouch
so don't even tell me how to get to
Sesame Street that is a terrible place I
want to go there if I knew the way
who would want to live in a neighborhood
like that [ __ ] six foot pigeons
walking around
an elephant that's a junkie
[Applause]
bird I'm sick I need some smack bird
the Cookie Monster with his eyes popping
out his head cookie cookie cookie like
Ugh
kind of cookies are you talking about
chocolate chips don't do that to people
and then I had the nerve to put a pimp
on there
[Music]
they didn't come out and say he's a pimp
but I know a pimp when I see you on that
they called him the count
[Applause]
look at that sand pimping [ __ ] where
does my money
you've been late four times I've been
counting
how many times must I smack you before
you act right
one two
two spots
[Applause]